a total of
29.95 milliliters of 1.25 molar
hydrochloric acid is required to reach
the equivalence point calculate the
concentration of potassium sorbate when
you put the brackets they're talking
about concentration in the stock
solution so let's just remind ourselves
what the equivalence point is
the equivalence point is the point at
which
in at which all of the potassium sorbate
has reacted with the acid with the
titrant so we have just gotten to the
right hand side of this net ionic
equation so another way to think about
it is it's the point in which because we
are reacting for every for every mole of
the potassium sorbate that we want to
turn into sorbic acid we're adding a
mole of the hydrochloric acid so one way
to think about the equivalence point is
if i've added one point if i've added a
certain number of moles of hydrochloric
acid that must be the exact number of
moles of the potassium sorbate that we
started out with we've we've added the
exact number of molecules of
hydrochloric acid as there originally
were a potassium sorbate so they can
completely cancel out with each other so
if we can figure out the number of moles
of hydrochloric acid here then we could
say well at the equivalence point
or if you needed that number of moles of
hydrochloric acid to reach the
equivalent point then that means your
original stock solution had that many
moles of potassium sorbate and then we
can use that to calculate the actual
concentration so let's do the first part
let's think about how many moles of
hydrochloric acid this is right over
here so i'll just write h
cl
and so if we have
29.9
milliliters
and let's let's convert it into liters
because if we have if our concentration
is given in in in terms of molarity this
is moles per liter so let's make sure we
get our units right so let's multiply
this times so we want to convert this to
liters so we want liters in the
numerator and milliliters in the
denominator so these cancel out so 1
liter is equal to 1000 milliliters and
that makes sense if you want to go from
milliliters to liters you would multiply
by one thousandth or divide by a
thousand so this will give us this will
give us the total amount of hydrochloric
acid solution we've
added in liters and now let's figure out
how many moles that will be well we
multiply that times the molarity times
1.25
instead of writing molar capital m i'm
going to write 1.25
moles
per
liter and what is this going to give us
well let me get my
calculator out
and so i'm going to have 29.95
divided by 1000 and that part right
there times 1.25 times 1.25
is equal to and let's see i have three
significant figures here four over here
so the product i'm going to have three
so 0.036
so
0.0374
and the units all work out milliliters
cancels out with milliliters liters
cancel out with liters and i have 0.00
moles remember this is moles of
hydrochloric acid so when they say that
a total of 29.95 milliliters of 1.25
molar solution of hydrochloric acid is
added they really added this many moles
of hydrochloric acid so that means our
original solution had that many moles of
had that many moles of potassium sorbate
so it had that many moles of potassium
sorbate we can now figure out the
original concentration of potassium
sorbate so
the concentration of our potassium
sorbate
c6h7o2
is going to be equal to the number of
moles of potassium sorbate our stock
solution starts off with so that's going
to be the same number right over here
0.0374
moles divided by
divided by well what was our original
volume of our original solution
let's see
a student tritrates
45.00 so we have four significant
figures here student titrates 45
milliliters of the stock solution
so the stock solution originally has a
volume
of 45 milliliters so 45 milliliters if
we wanted to write that in terms of
liters remember the concentration the
molarity here we wanted it in terms of
mole we want in terms of moles per liter
so
45 milliliters is the same thing as
0.045
i can write 0 0 there to show that i
have 4 significant figures here
liters of solution and what is this
going to be equal to and i just divided
this by a thousand 45 milliliters is the
same thing as 45 000
of a liter
and so what do we have
so we could take that number we just had
and then we divided it by
.045 and i could add two more zeros
there but from the calculator's point of
view it doesn't make a difference
and that's going to be equal to
all right and how many significant
figures do we have we have three
significant figures so
0.832
zero
point
eight three two moles per liter or we
could say zero point eight three two
molar did i write that right
yeah eight three two
and there and there you have it that's
the initial concentration of the
potassium sorbate in our stock solution